[Music]
what's up guys
jared again today we're talking about
one of the most nuanced takes on geek
culture out there
the big bang theory bazinga
yep nope not even close it's bad like
really bad
in fact it's become somewhat of a
recurring gag for us to hate on this
show
so when you sadistic maniacs asked for
what went wrong
we reached out to one of our unfortunate
writers thomas
but instead of making this poor bastard
watch all 5175 minutes of this show
we just hopped on imdb and grabbed the
top 10 rated episodes
sorry we cannot afford to pay this man's
therapist but i digress
why is a show that deals with science
comics and all that good wisecrack stuff
so bad well after hours of grueling
research
we suspect it might have something to do
with references
so it's subtle the fate of doctor who's
tardis will be decided by a game of
thrones inspired death match on the
battlefield of thundercats vs
transformers
see the big bang theory isn't just bad
it's
profoundly bad it's so bad that it
requires philosophy to understand just
how
bad it is so join me as i attempt to
convince you that the big bang theory is
proof
that meaning is dead welcome to this
wisecrack edition on the big bang theory
what went wrong and big shout out to the
real mvp thomas for watching this
garbage
the big bang theory loves referentiality
they reference cornerstones of nerd
culture like star trek
sheldon's log stardate six
three three four five point three for
battlestar galactica
that's my original series battlestar
galactica flight suit
and even scientific facts and
mathematical formulas they're slipped in
to remind us
over and over again that leonard sheldon
and company
are die-hard nerds they buy comics
perform science experiments and
sometimes describe very
basic things like slipping in a bathtub
like this
not surprising you have no safety mat or
adhesive stickers to allow for purchase
on a surface with a low coefficient of
static friction
now in case you missed the laugh track
sheldon giving penny the definition of
friction
was the joke you see it's funny because
it's a reference
now if you're wondering why you feel a
bit cheated at the punch line here
it's probably because that definition of
friction was simply slotted in there any
other scientific statement about the
nature of reality feels like
it could have had the same effect here
like gravity for instance
and cue the next joke oh my god i gotta
go to the emergency room
well assuming you're correct that your
right humerus is no longer seated in the
glenoid socket i would certainly think
so
they could have replaced the words
humorous and glenoid socket with
gibberish and most wouldn't know the
difference
and that's the problem the actual
science isn't the joke
but the fact that they're talking about
science is
friction isn't funny the reference to
friction is funny
by contrast consider this brief futurama
reference for somebody who barely
understands math like me
the reference will probably evade
detection but for those who spot the
symbol for aleph null
the mathematical symbol for an infinite
scent of countable numbers
they'll realize the theater is implying
there's an infinite number of screens
this not only gives an easter egg for
the mathematically inclined but more
importantly
the joke is the impossibility of a movie
theater having infinite screens
the joke is about the subject of aleph
null not the mere
reference to it the reference imbues the
joke with additional meaning
whereas the big bang theory accomplishes
the opposite
leonard do you recall when i said that i
was going to revolutionize humanity's
understanding of the higgs boson
particle and you said sheldon it's 2 am
get out of my bedroom
these jokes are at best lazy writing
and at worst a small step toward the
complete
annihilation of reality yes might sound
extreme but
these kind of references with no subject
is exactly what kept french philosopher
jean beaudrillard up at night
to vodriad we are living in a state
where reality has been obliterated
he gives four levels of representation
the first level is like a picture
a perfectly accurate representation of
reality the second level of
representation is the
unfaithful copy a filter that makes you
look prettier
thus obscuring your actual face below
that is the third level of
representation
one that deliberately hides the fact
that there's no reality being
represented
like an artist rendering a view where
they've never actually seen you
and finally the fourth level is reserved
for when signs and representations
start referencing other signs and
representations and all sense of reality
is thrown out the window
this is when people start photoshopping
a photoshopped image or making memes of
other memes
in baudrillard's eyes we're already
living in a world controlled by a system
of fourth order simulacra
or any reference to the original reality
is lost
which might explain why he technically
considers our reality
a simulation now if we're being
optimistic the big bang theory is a
distorted view of real nerd culture the
second order of representation
it gets a lot of the details wrong but
is still about
real nerd culture but if we're being
pessimistic and oh
we are it's a show about nerd culture
that has no relation to reality
whatsoever the third order of
representation a copy of something that
never existed it has science without
actual science
it's about nerd culture without real
nerds they're more like what someone who
has never met a nerd
thinks they're like that's where the bad
science references become relevant to
beaudry art
more often than not jokes rely on
characters cramming in whatever
scientific explanation is relevant to
the action when
are roadways most slippery now okay
there are three answers
none of which are correct the correct
answer is when covered by a film of
liquid sufficient to reduce the
coefficient of static friction between
the tire and the road to essentially
zero
but not so deep as to introduce a new
source of friction
they're references for the sake of
references jokes that don't rely on any
understanding of the science but
rather the simple recognition that this
is a scientific reference
it's the difference between sheldon
explaining how locks work when penny's
locked out
can't get the damn key out well it's not
surprising
that baldwin lock on your door uses
traditional edge mounted cylinders
whereas the key for your volkswagen uses
a center cylinder system
and when leela and the professor are
racing in futurama one more lap
nah half a lap you've forgotten the
mobius strip two laps is one lap
your kids and your topology in the
former the
joke doesn't rely on an audience
understanding how locks actually work
the reality is irrelevant as long as we
recognize that sheldon is being
unnecessarily smart
whereas in futurama we're laughing at
the actual science referenced in the
joke for beaudry heart as things
progress
these copies of reality end up becoming
their own reality
and this is where we see beaujolais
dismal vision reflected in the big bang
theory
these copies divorce from reality either
partly or entirely
signal not only the death of meaning but
make all
ideas interchangeable because the jokes
in the show are apropos of nothing
the characters can essentially spew
meaningless nonsense under the guise of
a meaningful joke
like in the show's game mystic warlords
of ka'ah which starts as a kind of joke
about magic the gathering
invisibility spell luminescence spell
and then quickly descends into utter
nonsense two-headed tiger three-headed
lion
sulfur brimstone it doesn't matter if
they said two-headed tiger three-headed
lions seven-headed ethical logan paul or
frankfurt school jam encrusted beetle
monster
the joke will work on the audience no
matter what they say
because the show functions at a level of
selling you an empty joke
under the guise of a meaningful one so
here's the big question
it's not over is it if the big bang
theory's use of reference for references
sake
ultimately points at nothing then what
are we laughing at
my hair is growing at the rate of 4.6
yaked meters per femtosecond
or at least what is the studio audience
laughing at it is scientifically
impossible
for a person to tip a cow seriously
somebody please tell me
her news sounded important but what
you're forgetting is it was an
achievement in the field of biology
that's all about yucky squishy things
well after conducting a rigorous study
our team of media experts has come up
with an answer
the show basically just shits on its
characters that's all that's happening
princeton a fine institution
the place where albert einstein taught
and where leonard got his phd
so it may have gone downhill
like when leonard and raj think about
buying howard a prostitute following a
recent breakup she's exactly a stipe
a hookah you know
i bet if we hired her that would cheer
him up we're not going to get wallow
with a hooker
i'm so lonely and horny i may open this
20
jar of peanuts and end it all
or like when sheldon defends his
girlfriend stewart's kind of
interested in amy of course he is she's
very interesting
did you know when she was 14 she severed
the webbing between her own toes
as it turns out ripping on people is
actually how the philosophy of humor
started
in the west the earliest theory of humor
is the superiority theory
which began with plato saying that
laughter was a form of scorn
the people we laugh at are generally
unaware of how awful they are which
invites our laughter later on thomas
hobbes modified this a little bit by
saying that laughter was a result of our
competitive nature
when we laugh it's either because we're
triumphing over another or
watching their downfall hell even dake
heart waded into the discussion calling
laughter the result of scorn which
proceeds from our perceiving
a small evil in a person whom we
consider to be deserving of it
in the end all three philosophers agree
that when we laugh
it's at the expense of others to make
ourselves feel good
while this might seem pretty obvious the
big bang theory isn't seinfeld
these aren't horrible people deserving
our scorn case in point
showrunner chuck lori literally said the
show is not about geeks or nerds but
about extraordinary people
so if they're so extraordinary why do
they deserve to be [ __ ] on
which brings us to the big picture
problem instead of building up
nerd culture the big bang theory kind of
tears it down
when the show simply pays lip service to
nerdum mechanically inserting
any reference for reference's sake the
show reveals its contempt for real nerds
the details of nerd culture are
irrelevant as long as they sound like
wanky [ __ ] it's close enough
what you doing i'm attempting to view my
work as a fleeting peripheral image so
as to engage the superior colliculus of
my brain
and while the show can fall back on its
laugh track or rip on its characters how
long has he been stuck
intellectually about 30 hours
emotionally about 29 years
ultimately this does all of us nerds
from the buffy fans to the marvel fans
a disservice instead of finding
ourselves reflected on screen
we see caricatures that kind of just get
dumped on
so what do you think wisecrack are we
being too harsh on the biggest show in
the world
or are we being a bunch of jealous
haters i'm the wing man
yep not that one